Again, we have a question with no solid right or
wrong answer. There are several different relationships that we coul
predict with this individual. Great
grandparents, grand uncles/aunts, first cousins.
And there's a lot of information we could use to
help figure out which of those groups best fits. We
could look at the age of the individuals. We could
compare the Y and mitochondrial chromosomes, the haplogroups, to see
how that fits in. We can even look at interesting
patterns of X chromosome matching. Obviously, the more information that's
able to be shared between the two individuals is going to
facilitate the best particular guess that we're able to give
that person to tell them what the possible relatedness is.
Now as far as advice to give to help them
connect, probably some of the best advice is, whatever it
takes for them to be prepared for the outcome that
it could be. As you can imagine, these relationships, and these
surprises and non surprises, very differently vary from
person to person. I'm going to draw your attention
one more time to the family rainbow that
we've seen in lessons five and lessons 11
in this course. The representation of helping you
see what the different genetic relatedness. What your
relationships are with different people in your family
in this sort of hierarchical way. 100% to you,
50% to your mothers, 50% to your parents and siblings, 25% on the next rung,
12% on the next rung. And you keep going out, and each time you go out, you
sort of half the amount of information. Ultimately, you've
got to be a good Sherlock Holmes. You've
got to use context clues, and you've gotta
talk to people. Genetic genealogy is an amazing profession.